but first it's been a tumultuous week
for the washington redskins to say the
least
first they caved to the mob and changed
their name now 15 former employees say
the organization
is a toxic workplace for women reporter
dax holt has been following this story
and joins us now
dax this looks terrible
this is uh this is a pretty serious
story uh but thanks for having me brian
so basically the red
washington ride skins on your daniel
daniel snyder has faced a lot of current
survivors here the last little bit first
the impounding pressure to change the
team's 87 year old name
and now like you said 15 former female
employees have come forward
in a washington post exclusive detailing
numerous instances
of alleged sexual harassment and an
unhealthy work environment in the
article
the women describe the culture of fear
and belittlement the article went on to
say
it was a place where executives berated
them commented inappropriate about their
appearance
and left the women feeling helpless
about their complaints when
about executives were ignored the story
did however point out that the nfl team
did not have the proper
structure in place to handle these
complaints one full-time staffer for
about 220 full-time employees
some of the women did tell the post that
they were often informally told
by other veteran employees which males
to avoid in the hallways which
stairwells to avoid
because it could lead to men looking up
their skirts as for daniel snyder
himself
he was not accused of sexual harassment
but more as a boss who belittles his
senior employees
one former employee went on to tell a
story where they allege that snyder
after a meeting would berate one of his
senior management members saying that he
would make fun of the fact that he was a
cheerleader in high school
or in college and made him do cartwheels
down the hall snyder declined to comment
on this story they now have two law
firms working on this one
to handle this situation the other the
name change
hey dax what kind of reputation does
daniel snyder have besides
underachieving on the field
and firing coaches well i
you know there's been a lot of stories
over the years so uh
you know sometimes these things catch up
with you is pretty much all i can say
three employees accused of improper
behavior abruptly departed
larry michael the club's long-time radio
voice alex santos the team director of
personnel
uh and this could get uh really bad it's
it is like uh sounds this reads like
animal house
uh except absolutely it's no john
belushi and it's not a comedy it's
deadly serious
thanks so much dax appreciate it